there's suddenly out nowhere after of  everyone being lovely much lighting you  and and then somebody says powerful  winds and they start pulling out like Oh  list of things because I was honest in  my book  and that's all they've written it in  this whole page and kind of not sure you  know and saying why would that go to her  why you know and anyway why do you want  it rain on my parade why do you want to  do that you know so that works that was  all but then I forget that's what it's  all about you know and so it's just for  a moment I went oh and it's always from  somewhere you don't expect or paper you  don't expect or you know maybe a report  you don't expect